He's got supporters.
Detroit, New York, Los Angeles.
Inciting large-scale arrests and sympathy marches.
I am very aware of that, Mr. Hoover.
What I do know is, he's nonviolent.
What I need to know right now, what's Martin Luther King about to do next?
Mr. President, Dr. King is here.
We will not tolerate agitators attempting to orchestrate a disturbance in this state!
It is unacceptable that they use their power to keep us voiceless!
Those that have gone before us say, "No more!"
We must march!
We must stand up!
We must make a massive demonstration!
My eyes have seen the glory, glory, glory, hallelujah!
What happens when a man stands up and says, "Enough is enough?"